okay so Jamie Fox is being sued for
allegedly sexually assaulting a woman
referred to as Jane do and 2015 at a
rooftop bar in New York so again guys
this is the vague language we talk about
what is sexual assault okay and who is
Jane do why do we not have a name to the
face in 2015 at a rooftop bar why did it
take you so long and guys after a
certain point it is tough to believe
real victims if there are real victims
because of the amount of [__] that I
have scene come up according to a
lawsuit Fox complimented The Woman Led
her to a secluded area so then my next
question is why are you going to a
secluded area with a man that you do not
want to have relations with do you see
how that's a little bit confusing and
proceeded to grope her breasts and
sexually assault her against her will
the lawsuit mentions that a security
guard allegedly witnessed the incident
but did not
intervene well if you were screaming and
crying wh why wouldn't he
intervene I mean I'm not saying it
didn't happen it could have I just have
questions that need to be answered um it
also implicates that Mark burning bomb
the bar owner and catch New York City
holding them responsible for enabling
the all an inadequate supervision while
than their New York adult survivors act
the lawsuit seeks compensation for
various damages including emotional
distress and physical pain with the
women alleging she required medical
treatment due to the assault Fox's
Representatives have not yet responded
to the allegations okay so we see this
time and time again I would say in
general real assault victims come
forward at least within a month at least
within a month um but when you're coming
back years later when this man is more
successful R rich and handsome than ever
I I just have questions you know why
would a guy with money Fame and Status
need to assault somebody um I I'm going
to wait for the facts to come out we'll
see but right now I'm just not buying
this um I'm not buying it at all why
won't you use your real name if really
happened um why what is sexual assault
and why were you going to a secluded
area with him doesn't make sense okay so
amongst the younger generation not only
can we not listen to Alternative points
of view and do we believe in these woke
nonsense um women nowadays are [__]
than ever it is actually crazy Annie a
26-year-old content creator from
Australia's Gold Coast shared her
experience with the Kyle and and Jackie
show discussing her active sex life as
empowering she claimed to have engaged
in sexual encounters with over 300
people in a year finding it exciting and
empowering emphasizing that sex is meant
to make you feel good she used dating
apps in her only fans page to find
Partners reportedly earning $1,000 daily
from only fans where she's in the top 4%
of content creators Annie has eight
regular Annie has eight Reg partners and
is comfortable with both men and women
sexually I'm sure she is Jesus
appreciating these different qualities
without favoring one over the other
while comfortable with her lifestyle her
only fans page caused her trouble at her
previous job I'm shocked I I shock and a
I'm so shocked oh my dear after the
company discovered her page she was
terminated for not disclosing her side
business and allegedly having
pornographic images online however
despite this SE setback she's estima to
have earned over a million yearly
through only fans now okay so I have a
couple questions and I want you guys to
think about this what is the future for
this woman is she going to be
responsible with her money no sex
workers are not typically responsible
with the money they earn it does not
matter how much money she gets typically
these women blow it and have no plan for
after their sexuality disappears maybe
as a sex worker you can make it till 35
making good money but they drop off over
the age of 35 sex workers are not doing
pornographic content like they used to
because we all know deep down that men
like younger women and my question is
how what is she going to do the rest of
her life these women are going to live
to be like 80 guys she's got another 50
years ahead of her women are willing to
sacrifice their entire future of having
a husband and a family for money and
this is the this is why we're so out of
order today you know it used to go God
men women children and now it goes money
women children men that's that's the New
Order of the world and women prove it
time and time again with their decisions
okay so as you guys know on the show I
have spoke about how women have truly
awful mate selection choices like truly
awful and how we see this trend
of men that are murderers and criminals
having a line of women waiting to date
them for whatever reason women we just
we just pick terrible so OJ Simpson is
now speaking in interviews how women are
lined up to date him let's pull it up I
got to get an itinerary on you because
your golf days switch up from your
hangout days and one day you might be at
the spot I met you at on Wednesday but
you going near Sun I gotta get a
itinerary because you moving around like
you younger than
me yeah well you you you be surprised
how many girls got father issues and
granddaddy
issues hey yo I hey yo old now we
go now now we going to go there oh I
wasn't going I wasn't going to let the
cat out the bag be shocked that how many
of them girls got granddaddy
issues said the stats of the world got
got granddaddy
issues before before we even get to
sports I want to know give me an example
of a female that had a granddaddy issue
that you you encountered uh uh this one
was from New Hampshire it was one that I
like so I gotta you know say I did like
her and it wasn't a fleeting thing I
mean it lasted at least three
days and
uh oh you do it three days oh I'm G get
you
that that to go back to
school back
okay hold on where was where did this
where was y'all at she's from New
Hampshire but where were y'all at were
y'all in
Florida we're in South Beach I mean not
South Beach we're on the beach and
there's a street called Los olis
Boulevard yeah it's to me the best
Street in America okay for clubs bars
and goodlooking women so basically my
buddies what you trying to tell me this
oh when I want to go out and get some
girls bring you with
me yeah well
you want some fresh new girls you know
what I mean okay say no more they love
Uncle okay OJ's been outside in Miami
you know the more you know going viral
let you know
that okay so this is a guy that I mean I
guess was technically found not guilty
for killing his wife but he wrote a book
called if I did it so women know this is
a violent
uh criminal or at least he has the
capacity for violence and yet they're
lined up to sleep with him women don't
care women do not select men well and
and the he's talking about women that
seem like they're College age so young
women are are this is what they're
picking um okay so the comment section
weighs in on this and the comment
section
says American women are a different
breed how are you giving this old man
and then continuing your days the shame
yeah I know I know and this is why guys
say nice guys finish last okay some dude
was ghosted by his girl for three days
just to see
this no no can you imagine if you found
out your girlfriend cheated on you with
OJ Simpson okay old men stay winning
because all these girls got Daddy Issues
see big Ed from 90day fiance for a case
study yeah for whatever reason clout
money and
looks women don't really care there have
been women or there have been men that
put up a fake page where the guy was a
literal pedo but he was good-looking
with it looked like money and status and
the women didn't care